lucas giolito on for his 22nd start
looking for his ninth win as cra at 367.
lots of strikeouts 143 of them and 125
innings
his first pitch swinging lately going to
right i'd like to see him get the head
out and pull one
he's been staying inside the ball which
is good but he has good ability to turn
on one
just like that he heard you
challenging my inner wit right now let's
go buddy get on the board early
it starts a new hitting streak after
losing a 12 gamer last night
salvador perez backstop for kansas city
tonight
we'll bat with one away and whitmerfield
on first
salvi lines it into center field and
whit
is going to make the turn and now put on
the brakes look at that swing nice
short to the ball that's what we need to
see royall's offense do
excuse me and with whit going to third
he's going to be in there
with this major league leading 28th
it's a good combo to run on g alito and
collins
oh excellent jump moving the guys
santana he didn't have a chance
or a salvy sorry he didn't go with him
and you can't expect him to
and o'hearn hits a change up into right
field
and going across the line is sheets
so here's whit coming down from third
and the royals take a one-nothing lead
in the first inning
facing carlos hernandez and carlos had
the best
appearance of his big league career the
last time he faced the white sox that
was
thursday in an afternoon game at
kauffman stadium and the royals won that
game
five nothing that's right stay calm stay
confident
and throw strike one they can put it in
play
got him that was supposed to be down and
away but it was 98 up and in
got him with a changeup so hernandez
strikes out two in the bottom of the
first
giolito on a one-two here's another
swing and miss
and a strikeout his first of the night
that's a change up and there's a lot of
pitchers
right-handed won't throw changes to
right-hand hitters i honestly can't see
why not
it's such a devastating pitch and lucas
throws one of the best change-ups in
baseball
giolito work against edward olivares the
right fielder
pulled into the left field corner and it
is gone edward olivares
has a home run now in three of his last
four starts
and he stayed back just long enough on
that changeup
and the royals lead two nothing in the
second inning beautiful swing he stayed
with it and stuck it
[Applause]
slider has bounced up the middle and
that's into center field
lopez rounds third and the royals
get a two-out run and whitmerfield has
two hits in the first two innings
and the royals lead three nothing oh
nicely done zombie
single to center field his first time up
see if he challenges him with a fastball
he does and salvi gets on top of it and
drills it deep to left field over the
bullpens
and that's a two run home run and
salvador perez
has tied his career high with 27 home
runs
and the royals lead five nothing in the
third inning oh
man i was hoping he would challenge him
and when i
saw the catcher zach collins move inside
that's a that's a fastball coming in
and savvy was waiting on it and the
royals have scored
in the first three innings against gia
lito one in the first two in the second
two in the third taylor grounded out to
short his first time up
and a breaking ball is whacked to deep
left field
it is a fair ball off the screen
and the royals have scored in four
straight innings against gia lito
that is their third home run tonight and
it's
six nothing in the fourth i know jose
has been out taking some early batting
practice because he's not particularly
happy about that 242 number
[Applause]
deep center taylor back at the wall
gone sox on the board
jose is sneaking up on the rbi leaders
once again trying to accomplish that the
american league three straight years
he's got 81. this is a low four-seam
fastball
i don't think hernandez wanted to throw
it down there
jose just hits a line drive rocket
out of the park the 400 foot mark
so this is a test now there's a ground
ball
third rivera throws and it's in time
with plays on both sides of the diamond
emanuel rivera throws from foul ground
and got some help on the stretch by
carlos santana
oh man that's a highlight reel if i've
seen one
fawn is running and collins strikes out
well it won't go down as a quality start
but for all intents and purposes it was
fantastic
left center field and taylor goes into a
dive to make the play
that was a tough play for him because
off the left-hand
bat that was just working away from him
the whole time sure
was but that good speed he's able to
catch up to it for sure or heard but
that's
nice at bats to see if he can get him
[Music]
drilled to center field back goes
goodwin he is at the wall
and it's gone ryan o'hearn
hits the royals fourth home run tonight
on a 1-2
pitch and the royals lead 8-1
in the seventh inning and i you know no
wonder he didn't want to throw him the
fastball three curves in a row and he
was waiting for that heater
he didn't try to pull it just went with
it high fastball
caught it just right good level swing
there's a base hit into left center
field and the royals will score again
they will score with two outs again
nikki lopez in front of
friends and family has two hits an rbi
and the royals lead 9-1
got him to chase and abreu says you know
what
we'll worry about that another time
wow royals are gonna move up to
seven and eight against the white sox
this year four
and four in chicago
and with a win tomorrow they would win
back-to-back series
against the white sox and rivera in the
shortstop position
seals the wind